vous avez peut-être suivi ces derniers
jours l'altercation en ligne qui a
opposé Thierry Breton le commissaire
européen français au marché intérieur et
Elon Musk propriétaire du réseau social
x anciennement appelé Twitter en effet
Elon Musk laisse sa plateforme propager
des contenus et de la désinformation
depuis les attaques terroristes du Hamas
contre Israël et Thierry Breton l'a
sommé de faire appliquer la loi
européenne musk joue un jeu très
dangereux en fermant les yeux sur la
prolifération des conten illégaux en
censurant des comptes de journalistes
voire même en prenant parti ouvertement
pour des formations d'extrême droite
nous ne laisserons pas notre démocratie
aux mains d'un patron de plateforme
américaine sans fois ni lois en
particulier car beaucoup d'états-membres
sont en période d'élection et que
l'année prochaine auront lieu les
élections
européennes comme vous le savez les
contenus sensibles sont virux et se
répondent à une vitesse effrainée sur
Internet la bonne nouvelle c'est que
depuis quelques mois l'Union européenne
s'est doté d'un outil la législation sur
les services numériques ou DSA qui pour
la première fois demande aux plateformes
en ligne de retirer les contenus
illicites et d'étudier leurs algorithmes
pour qu'il n'encouragent pas la
circulation de fausses informations ou
encore d'appel à la haine et la
conséquence c'est que l'ultimatum de
l'Union européenne à Elon Musk pourra si
nous estimons que la réponse n'est pas
suffisante mener à une amende de 6 % du
chiffre d'affaires mondial de X voir à
une interdiction du réseau pour l'Union
européenne en ces temps difficiles il
est particulièrement important de faire
attention aux informations que nous
faisons circuler mais heureusement nous
avons désormais les armes pour mettre
fin au Far West numérique et faire en
sorte que les musques Zuckerberg et
autres respectent nos règles
européennes